Swiss engineering has a reputation for being
precise and reliable.
And the country has a reputation for being...
not paranoid, exactly,
but at least taking a lot of precautions about
their safety.
Switzerland is the only country in the world
with enough nuclear fallout shelters for the
entire population.
Even now, it's a legal requirement that any
new build house here
must have a shelter if it's not close enough
to an existing one.
And okay, a lot of those shelters are being
used mostly for storage these days,
probably for cheese, but if the world takes
a dark path?
Switzerland is ready.
And that extends to this.
The drinking water.
I'm in Zurich, the largest city in Switzerland,
and it has an entire backup water supply system.
The city has hundreds of drinking fountains,
free for public use,
of all sorts of designs.
And okay, most of them are fed from the same
pipes as homes and offices:
it's mostly filtered water from nearby Lake
Zurich,
with a bit of spring water and ground water
mixed in.
It is, of course, some of the safest drinking
water in the world.
Because Switzerland.
But in the event of an emergency:
let's say the lake was contaminated somehow,
or there's a days-long power cut that shuts
all the pumps down:
not that that's likely, because the electricity
supply is just as secure,
but if it happens: Zurich is still prepared.
There is an entire backup water system,
fed by nothing more than gravity from a spring
on a nearby mountain.
It runs through 150 kilometres of pipes to
taps in hospitals and fallout shelters,
and special drinking fountains like this.
These can all be adapted so they can fill
a lot of buckets
in a very short amount of time
with nothing more than some hoses and scaffolding.
This water isn't being wasted, by the way.
I mean, it is, no-one's drinking it,
but if it wasn't going through these pipes
it'd just be joining a river and heading straight
to the ocean by a different path.
Lots of cities maintain some level of redundant
water supply:
some backup pipes, or emergency tankers in
case everything fails.
But Zurich?
They have two systems, constantly tested,
always running together.
Just in case the world ends.